just feel like you can see the trailer
already for craving the hunter it's just
like a false anti-hero
yeah like trying to pitch it as like a
bad guy but then you could see like
those the overly serious trailer but you
could tell it's going to be like b-movie
cheesy from the very opening scene of
the movie you're like this guy's going
to be a full good guy by the end here we
go
well well well citizens of the reject
nation and greg here johnny how is your
day going it has been spooktacular g
it's good to hear johnny so you know
we've talked a lot about the mcu lately
we have talked about dc as well we
haven't talked about the best one of
them all
the s
sony spiderman's crap that they got
going on
the ssc sony's spiderman crap mixed bag
universe
with a fantastic animated spider-verse
thing going on yeah that's what we have
going we got two things to talk about
two things that when i saw him online
i'm like my god soda you are not hyping
me up right now i'm just skeptical i'm
just more skeptical we got to talk about
some madame webb set photos there's ones
that people talked about recently that
were indicative of spider-man and now
there's a new one that is even more
connected to spider-man more than ever
now we got to talk about some craven the
hunter updates aaron taylor johnson did
an interview talking about this stuff so
before we go into all that leave a like
doesn't take a lot of work hunt down
that like button and web it first we'll
talk about craven the hunter so there
was this thing that aaron taylor johnson
said and it's not being taken out of
context he really said this he said that
like a while ago craven he's not an
alien or a wizard he's just a hunter a
human with a conviction an animal lover
and a protector of the natural world is
a very very cool character i actually
have no idea what aaron taylor johnson
sounds like that's like he was in the
room and honestly when i heard it i just
burst into laughter i read it online and
i was just i told it to olivia and i
just kept laughing
i'm like this sounds so stupid it's a
faux fur craving man and then he wanted
to clarify we're not going to read
everything but we'll read the most
important stuff without losing the
context john oh and you're best and
better than greg british yes please read
this updated quote and we're going to
talk about what aaron taylor johnson
said to
to backpedal and save the sunny
spider-man universe because what he said
the first time just did not sound like
the craving we were all hoping for
it's all on his lion-clad shoulders he
said i guess that was probably a little
taken out of context and then run i mean
i think you know what i meant and really
what stated was that he was a protector
of the natural world i said and he's a
conservationist which is probably more
accurate then i should have stopped
there full stop he's a hunter and from
there that world of hunting and there's
so many aspects what i love about the
character is that
what he is humanizing is that he has
flaws right craven is a beautiful
character sergey kravenov is a beautiful
character because it's someone who
really has understanding themselves and
has flaws this is a character that was
built ages ago and it's in a new time
and era
but yeah is he going to be the hunter
that we all want to see yeah absolutely
absolutely we did not hear the tone and
how he said it
when you're reading it here's what i'll
first say craven the hunter does have a
rich backstory there's a lot about
craven the hunter that could absolutely
be a standalone film the big thing that
he is what he ended with is is he going
to be the hunter that we all want to see
i just don't have the faith that it's
going to be what i think in an ideal
world is like if you want to do a craven
the hunter film just focus on craven and
then in a sequel do like craven's last
hunt do the movie where it's craven
versus spider-man because that's the
craven the hunter we all really want to
see and in terms of what he meant by
animal lover you know i i think one
thing he might be getting at is the fact
that you know like yes craven the hunter
has like awesome predatory cat like
abilities is an insane hunter obviously
that involves hunting prey part of his
abilities is he's like a master tamer of
animals to the point where people can
get misled into thinking it's like mind
control i think that's maybe what he was
referencing yeah to give the benefit of
the doubt because it's like there's a
version of that that sounds in tune with
the character he is a hunter but perhaps
he's one who is very in tune with the
land and has you know just as much
respect for his prey as he probably
enjoys killing it but to say stuff like
we're humanizing him that he has flaws
he's a beautiful character yes there's a
version of this where you can make an
actual anti-hero because craven is a
villain he should be introduced as a
villain or as if you're going to do
anti-hero make him a real
anti-hero from everything we've seen
from the saudi spider-man universe
morbius and venom those are movies i
don't hate i really don't hate them he's
probably gonna be in the trailers trying
to convince us he's an anti-hero then
you watch the movie you're like he's not
a night this guy is totally big he's
friendly to all the animals he probably
only hunts prey from other worlds
because it's probably a little
problematic it's from sony's perspective
to have a character you want everyone to
get behind who also is murking animals
left and right what they're doing right
now is sony's been rushing the sinister
six film i mean it's been a long build
up but with the amount of reboots now
they do things it's been feeling like
they're rushing to a sinister six movie
i feel like they want to get craving to
get involved into like the sinister six
film the fight of spider-man let's face
it i don't want to see craven the hunter
fight spider-man with a bunch of other
people i want to see the craven the
hunter making spider-man's life a living
hell
and just them too going toe-to-toe in
new york city that's the one i think for
fans of craven the hunter that they
really want so that's that what do you
guys think about this news does this
update that aaron taylor johnson give
did it make you feel more relief that
they might actually do this character
justice or as your faith in what sony's
been doing just whittle down absolutely
not anyway let's move on to madame web
we're not going to deep dive into the
madame webb character it's just a lot of
this is starting to read like morbius
again so john you want to update them on
what the photos were from last time and
then now what these new photos are a
quick update on the last so the early
leaked photo was basically just a urban
set with a beyonce album poster which
you can link back to the year
2003. that's significant that sets a
time and place for the movie and now on
the heels of that we've had a new photo
league news racks one has the raimi era
daily bugle logo on it and another one
from a daily news front page has an uh a
headline that reads bravest pulls girl
from fire what's significant about that
is if you look at spider-man 2 came out
in 2004 well uh enough time to overlap
with uh dangerously in love that beyonce
album this could be harkening to toby
maguire's spider-man
and it also could be
more sony [ __ ]
and that's the big worry right now is we
as we saw with morbius there was those
spider-man easter eggs and then it just
kind of all got shoehorned into the
post-credits scenes and it was not well
done it wasn't and uh so they promised
some of the worst post-credits i've ever
seen in my lifetime now the question is
like do we believe this well it's like
yeah no one really people don't know
this character as well so we need to
know the part of spider-man so yeah so
just we're just gonna use that as the
hook so you've done it in there so we're
telling people it's part of the
spider-man world and that way people
might be interested because of
spider-man spider-man's cool and people
like spider-man spider-man makes money
and then the movie will be good enough
to make them forget about spider-man
yeah yeah
oh yeah what happened to those scenes
though this will be an absolutely
forgotten about those it's not going to
be an actual like
thinking about it pouring over in
anticipation of a spiderman appearance i
could see it being more likely than
orbeez because i think whereas craving
the hunter they want to put them in
sinister six i think with madame webb
what they're setting up is to do their
multiverse movie a live-action version
of that that's what i feel like her
her stance in the universe building is
going to do is somehow lead into
something multiverse related nexus of
all the spider-man things maybe that's
the way you do have sinister six fight a
spider-man right that's kind of where my
mind is going with what they want to do
with madame webb these photos i don't
want to just be negative and get here
and then just be like it's a bunch of
crap because for all i know they might
actually tie this all in i'm just here
to tell you that
don't be surprised if any of these
things are actually not in the film
itself part of me believes that yes they
will eventually directly involve toby
and or andrews universes and maybe just
morbius was timed in a funky way that
they had to not do that but just the
same i could imagine just these trailers
existing in their own multiverse where
they have toby mcguire and the movies
actually don't so does this clarify what
world that takes place in it makes it
look like it's linking to the rainbow
movies but then they'll have a manager
garfield stuff
yeah
we'll see do you think this mata web
stuff is going to be actually legit and
tight and are you looking forward to the
madame web movie i actually like dakota
johnson i think she's a really great
actress sydney sweeney love her work on
euphoria so leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell leave a
like
and
pandemic jones cajons how's it going my
bros you my friend sound like a
spiderman villain and i want to see you
make your own costume that's what i want
this your homework for this month bud
get like a morph suit or some like
spandex personalize it with your own
pandemic themed uh you know motifs and
things and report back buddy these these
shoutouts are now assignments for you
you thought you could sit back and just
enjoy us you know talking you up about
how great you are and how cute your
thumbnail is how great your energy in in
live stream do it
costume
i like that that was shorter
[Music]